المتابعه معنا من بيروت الخبيره العسكري
والاستراتيجي الياس حنا اهلا بك جسر
شونغار ما معنى اي يستهدف الان في هذا
التوقيت من الحرب
مريم في هذه الحرب تحدثنا دائما عن
اللوجيستيه وخطوط المواصلات الروسيه
الطويله يعني اليوم عندما تقاتل روسيه ما
يسمى بالخطوط الخارجيه يعني لنقل قوات من
مكان الى اخر يستلزم وقت اكثر من القوات
الاوكرانيه التي تعمل ما يسمى بالخطوط
الداخليه هذا الجسر في هذه المنطقه هناك
جسرين اساسيين شونجار والكرش اشجار يصل
شبه جزيره قرن بيجون كوي وهي عقده لوجستيه
مهمه تم استهدافها سابقا من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه اليوم ظروف هذه على هذا هذه
الضربه او هذه الغاره او هذا القصف على
الجسر له علاقه مباشره بما قد يحصل
وما يحصل في زبروت الهدف دائما هو العزل
اللوجستي للقوات الروسيه
سياده العميد الجانب الروسي هدد دائما بان
استهداف الجسر الرابط بين شبه جزيره القرم
والاراضي الروسيه هو خط احمر لا يمكن
لموسكو ان تسمح بحدوثه كما انها قالت ان
استخدام صواريخ هايمرس وصواريخ ستورم شادو
يعد دخولا مباشرا للولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا على خط هذا الصراع ماذا يعني
هذا الكلام وما الذي يمكن ان تفعله موسكو
ردا على ذلك
محمود اليوم موسكو وصلت الى قمه التصعيد
ولكن اقل من استعمال النووي او التهديد به
وهي في مرحله التهديد وحتى نقل سلاح نووي
تكتيكي الى بيلاروسيا وقال مؤخرا رئيس
بوتين وهذا امر غريب يعني اصبح يعلق يوميا
على سير الاحداث العملانيه والتكتيكيه على
المسرح الاوكراني انه فعلا تم نقل هذه
الاسلحه الى بيلاروسيا اليوم ماذا يمكن ان
يفعل الرئيس بوتين الى حد التصعيد او رفع
مستوى التصعيدي ويقصف كل المدن
الاوكرانيه حتى المدنيه منها هو يقصف كل
البنى التحتيه من كهرباء وماء وهذا امر
مستمر منذ مرحله طويله سته او سبعه اشهر
فاذا مستوى التصعيد الى اي درجه مع العلم
انه
تعتبر بالمعنى القانون الدولي وحسب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبريطانيا ان
القرم هي منطقه اوكرانيه محتله يمكن
استعمال فيها السلاح وهذا ما تم استعماله
في شادو يقال ولكن استعمال محمود ستورم
شادو يقول لنا ان هذا السلاح يطلق من الجو
هو كروز يطلق من الجو يعني هناك تقدم في
مستوى استعمال الشادو او ستورم شادو انه
تدربت القوات الاوكرانيه عليه واصبحت
تطلقه من الجو عميد الياس حنا ما ذكرته
قبل قليل بان الهدف من استهداف مثل هذه
الجسور ومؤخرا هو العزل اللوجستي للقوات
الروسيه هل يتحقق ذلك فعلا للقوات
الاوكرانيه
مريم تحقق في حادثه سابقه ولكنها مختلفه
يعني عند الانسحاب من مدينه خرسون هو لم
ينسحب الجيش الروسي نتيجه هجوم مفاجئ عليه
ولكنه انسحب عندما استطاعت القوات
الاوكرانيه ان تقطع خطوط المواصلات بين
ضفتي النهر فتم الانسحاب الى الجبهه او
الضفه الشرقيه من النهر هذا الامر له
علاقه باللوجستيه اليوم هناك جسرين
اساسيين جسر ياتي
وهو كرش وهذا الجسر الاخر يضرب كل
المواصلات اليوم مركز الثقل الاساسي مريم
للهجوم الاوكرانيين سيكون في منطقه
ذابولوجيا اوريكيف توك ماك مينيتو بول
وبالتالي الوصول الى الحدود مع شبه
الجزيره هذا الامر يعيقه يعيقه كما قلت
انه روسيا تقاتل بالخطوط الخارجيه يعني
امكانيه الانتقال من مكاني لاخر نقل
اللوجستيه ونقل العتاد وحتى العديد يستلزم
وقتا وهذا امر تكسبه اوكرانيا في اي حرب
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من بيروت
شكرا جزيلا لك